this was once a busy vibrant City with
cultural buildings like this famous
drama theater now damaged and peppered
with bullets and bomb fragments Russian
forces won the battle for moriopal after
more than 80 Days of intense fighting
and now they want the people of the city
to move on from the scars of War to
Rehabilitation by 2025 the city should
be rebuilt according to moscow's
mariopal reconstruction master plan it
wants the population here to grow to
half a million people in the next decade
by rehabilitating a million square
meters of social buildings the Russian
State plans to fund a complete
replacement of the city's facilities
including a railway station a port tram
lines and the airport
well Russia different definitely tried
to take this territory into organize New
Life there but Russian authorities also
hope that Ukrainian political regime
would collapse so probably this was a
miscalculation and there was a necessity
to remake this plan no one can imagine
that if you have this long prolonged or
long-time conflict that people could
live safely there it just was not
possible to imagine according to a new
law passed by Russia State Doomer people
in the annex regions of Ukraine will
have the same benefits as Russian
citizens the legislation aims to provide
free medical care pensions and benefits
piece by piece people are trying to
rebuild their lives
we are going to redevelop we want to
live free as our grandfather's
grandmothers and relatives used to live
in our free territory where no one will
shoot at us tell us what to do and force
us to speak another language
a few hundred apartments and homes have
been rebuilt in the city with only a
fifth of the population is left
slowly basic services such as water and
electricity are returning
my house burned down on the Left Bank
near the sea it was at consumer
Boulevard about 50 meters from azov's
my son took us to his house so we can
live with him and his family
were annexed by Russia in September in
what western power is called a sham
referendum Moscow insists that people
chose their right to self-determination
despite Western condemnation but for the
hundreds of thousands of people in these
territories any help to rebuild their
lives is welcome
if there is no more fighting here it'll
take years to remove the scars of war
from the city of moriopol but for the
families of the thousands of people
killed in these territories no number of
new buildings or benefits can replace
their loss Moscow